We we do have now some of the sound.
As I told you, we're not in the audience.
We're not carrying his remarks live
because frankly,
he says a lot of things that are not true
and sometimes potentially dangerous.
But but we do have some a small portion.
So you can get a sense of
his state of mind
and how he might be framing his defense.
I want to get your reaction to it.
Let's we're going to start, of course.
I just want to note
is begins
this this clip we're about to show you
by making unfounded claims
about the charges against him.
Untrue and unfounded claims
about the charges against him
and the people he thinks are behind it.
So I just want to preface it
by saying that.
And then end of the clip.
You're going to hear him frame
what could actually be
part of his defense.
So here's a little clip
Today, we witnessed
the most evil
and heinous
abuse of power
in the history of our country.
Very sad thing to watch.
A corrupt sitting president had his top
political opponent arrested on fake
and fabricated charges
of which he
and numerous
other presidents would be guilty right
in the middle of a presidential election
in which he is losing very badly
This is called election interference
and yet
another attempt
to rig and steal a presidential election.
More importantly, it's a
political persecution,
like something straight
out of a fascist or a communist nation.
This day will go down in infamy.
And Joe
Biden will forever be remembered
as not only the most corrupt president
in the history of our country,
but perhaps even more importantly,
the president
who together with a band of his closest
thugs, misfits
and Marxists, tried to destroy
American democracy.
But they will fail, and
we will win bigger
and better than ever before.
The Espionage Act
has been used to go after traitors
and spies.
It has nothing to do
with a former president
legally keeping his own documents
as president.
The law that applies to
this case is not the Espionage Act,
but very simply,
the Presidential Records Act,
which is not even mentioned
in this ridiculous 44 page indictment
under the Presidential Records Act,
which is civil, not criminal.
I had every right to have these documents
Okay.
A lot to unpack there.
I'm not going to make you fact check.
But just quickly,
the Presidential Records Act,
that's the defense. He's going to bring.
That's fine.
There is no evidence
that he legally kept these documents.
They're not his documents.
They belong to the American people.
There's no evidence of the Joe
Biden had anything to do with this.
Charges brought by the special counsel.
The charges are not fake.
The charges are not fabricated.
He's not losing an election.
The election hasn't started
and he hasn't even gotten
the presidential nomination.
There's no evidence
this is election interference.
We do not live in a fascist state.
And in terms of
trying to destroy American democracy,
we all know who tried to actually
do undo an election.
And it's not Joe Biden.
It's Mr. Trump.
That's said. Your response?
You know, I think
Donald Trump is the king of saying
one thing
to his supporters
and doing another
doing the opposite in private.
And in this circumstance,
one of just the most brightest
examples of that is of him today coming
before his supporters and telling them
I was totally aboveboard.
I know that I was above board.
This was part
of the Presidential Records Act.
But what we see in
this indictment is a recording
and and also testimony of people
tell of him telling people close to him,
I could have declassified this.
I did not declassify this.
You shouldn't look at this. Right.
Because it is not allowed
because this is still a secret document.
So this is just Trump in true form.
And where he says
one thing to his supporters,
says another thing privately,
but then also insinuates
that he is a victim of a system
that has been developed
purely for his own privilege and benefit.
Do you think that I mean, we've
heard some clips
from Republicans on the Hill,
Congressman Don Bacon, a veteran
Republican from Nebraska,
now he's in a swing district.
But he's been very critical.
Obviously,
Chris Christie has been critical.
Bill Barr has been critical.
He's a Hutchinson who's running against
him has been critical.
Nikki Haley made comments of my
you know, these her husband's deploying.
If this kind of thing could get
my could put my husband's life at risk.
Do you see any break in the fever?
I mean,
have you heard from any Republicans on
Capitol Hill,
not just the Mike
Lawless of the world
who are already like Trump skeptics,
but that's a congressman from New York
for people who don't know.
I know, you know, but Republican.
But I mean, from other Republicans, are
people just sick of this already?
You know,
I do think that
what is happening
now is also layered
into a bubbling political tension
in what is happening in the House
right now.
Some of the House's
most staunch extremists who are also
some of Trump's
most loyalist members of the House,
have also ground legislating to a halt.
And there seems
it seems to have been made very clear
and they have sent a direct message
to Speaker McCarthy that McCarthy is
either going to follow their orders
or they're going to shut this whole place
down.
And that,
I think, has created an enormous schism
that is starting to happen
within House Republicans.
And this will absolutely exacerbate it,
because what is detailed
in this indictment
is completely indefensible.
On top of of a conviction around
rape charges
that just happened
out of the state of New York
and we don't even know
what's happening in Georgia yet.
This level of misconduct of criminality
is getting to a point
where it is indefensible.
And and I do believe
that we are approaching that point.
You talked about the Jean Carroll
rape charge is it's a civil
it's a civil case.
He was found liable
for sexual abuse
and I think he had to pay
$5 million, something along those lines.
A judge just ruled that Jean
Carroll could add
to her complaint against him
because he went after her and defamed her
at that Trump town hall. Absolutely.
Calling her a whack job.
What do you think of that?
Well, I mean, it also continues to convey
his commitment to intimidation
and to political intimidation.
Use of his platform towards intimidation.
And to think that that would stop simply
at one of his sexual assault victims is
very naive.
What we're seeing here,
as outlined in this indictment
and these documents
right now,
one of the things
that we had to hear out of this court
was that
he could not contact his body person
throughout this process,
because we have seen a pattern
that that suggests
a tendency towards obstruction of justice
I don't think he can.
He's now he's allowed to talk to me.
He's not allowed to talk to him
about the case. Right. Right. Correct.
So
one of the House Republicans,
Andy Biggs,
he is calling this a war phase.
He's a very obviously a Trump loyalist.
Republican Senator J.D.
Vance, another Trump loyalist,
has announced
that he's
going to hold
all nominees
to the Department of Justice.
He's going to block them
like no votes will be allowed on them,
he says, indefinitely because of
this indictment.
How I
mean, is Washington
just going to shut down,
do you think, ultimately?
Well, because you described the schism
already occurring that's
stopping the House
from doing its business.
I do think that that is the real question
that cuts
at the core of a decision
that the Republican Party
is going to have to make
if they are going to try
to survive
as a political party
in the United States.
We just saw that they experienced
much lower gains
than they thought they would
last year in the 20, 22
midterm elections.
We are also seeing the ramifications
of an extreme Supreme Court
that has several members
that were appointed by President Trump.
And additionally, with the erosion
of the legitimacy of the court,
with the conduct of Clarence Thomas,
Brett Kavanaugh and others,
the Republican Party
is very much at a crossroads right now.
And they are going to have to decide
if they are going to choose
a cult of personality or this country.
And that is what cuts
at the core of this case.
And I believe the American people
are also going to have to decide
if this
is something that we are going to accept.
And right now, you know,
what is very dangerous is that
Donald Trump is going
to have this case going
before a judge that that was appointed
during his administration
if it
if he somehow was able to delay this,
if he is somehow
or for whatever
reason, is able to clinch the nomination,
he will seek revenge.
I, I believe that.
And you're not the only one.
I mean,
Chris Christie said he thinks the in
if Trump gets elected
president again,
his entire
second term will be about revenge.
I believe so.
And what we saw during his first during
his first term
was was him putting undue influence
on on the FBI,
on the Department of Justice to engage in
in an agenda of political
in a politically motivated agenda.
We will see this
really cut to the core of our democracy
if it is not checked right now.
Congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez, Democrat of New York.
Good to see you.
Thank you so much for being here.
Really appreciate it.